mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
at a rectangular table are four
mathematicians a b c and d
they sit at the following distances to
the corners of the table
a salt shaker s is placed on the table
consider the distance from each person
to the salt shaker and take the sum of
these distances
at some point the sum of these distances
will be a minimum value
the question is what is the minimum
value of s a plus sb plus sc plus sd
this problem has tremendous practical
applications
you could imagine the four points are
either towns or railway stations and you
want to calculate the least amount of
roads or tracks that you would need to
connect these towns or railway stations
you could also imagine the four points
are friends and they want to calculate
the most environmentally friendly point
to meet that is the one that minimizes
the sum of the distances they have to
travel
you can really use this problem for many
applications in teamwork
i adapted this problem from a sri lanka
olympiad and i thank chanul for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
imagine we have four points in the plane
that form a convex quadrilateral
we want to determine the point s such
that the sum of distances to these four
points is a minimum value
we will prove the rather fascinating
result
s will be at the intersection of ac and
bd
first let's prove why this is true
consider the segment ac
for any point x in the plane
we can connect a x and xc
let's consider those distances
well by the triangle inequality ac will
be less than or equal to ax plus cx
then ac is equal to s plus c s
we will put this inequality to the side
and for the same point x we will
consider the line segment bd
we will do a very similar sort of
argument
by the triangle inequality bd is less
than or equal to bx plus dx
bd is equal to bs plus ds
we thus have another inequality
let's put these two inequalities
together by adding them
what happens
well on the left hand side we get the
sum of the four distances from each of
these points to s and on the right hand
side we have the sum of distances from
some other point x
and we have shown that s is a minimum
value no other point can be less than
that
therefore this is a minimal value
let's use this result to solve the
problem
we will first determine where s is by
connecting ac and bd
their intersection point will be s
from here we need to calculate a s plus
sc plus bs plus sd
we'll do that by using right triangles
first let's calculate the length of ac
we have one right triangle here
one leg will be equal to 22 and the
other leg will be equal to 60. therefore
we can calculate the length of the
hypotenuse using the gogu theorem and we
get 2 times the square root of 1021
this will be equal to as plus cs
we can then do the same sort of
calculation to determine the length of
bd
we have a right triangle where one leg
is 25 and the other leg is 40. we can
therefore calculate the length of bd
using the gogu theorem and we get 5
times the square root of 89
this will be equal to bs plus ds
we then can calculate the sum of the
four distances and that will be equal to
2 times the square root of 1021 plus 5
times the square root of 89 and that's
approximately
111.08 and that's our answer
it's a rather fascinating optimization
problem with an elegant geometric
solution
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
you